your skills are worthless but your
context is valuable my own experience of
being a social media marketing CEO for
10 years I did marketing for big fashion
brands and big consumer electronics
Brands 6 months to a year after I left
there I moved my skill set to the
Biotech Industry because one of my
friends built one of the biggest
psychedelics companies in the world my
skill set of social media and marketing
was in such low Supply in that industry
that the offer he made me was
outstanding and we think the way to get
ahead in life is to get promotions or to
ask our boss for a pay rise but if you
think about your core skill set and the
market in which you're selling your
skill set is it in low Supply in that
market and is the upside for the person
that is hiring me tremendous you can get
paid so much more they offered me $8
million in options for 9 months of work
there's no fast fashioned brand that
would have offered me that because the
return for the fast fashion brand would
have been 20,000 more dresses sold in
the Biotech Industry it was moving that
IPO price from potentially 1 billion to
3 billion so they could off 8 million is
a flash in the pan